to me social justice is a simple concept
it's the notion that all people in a
society deserve fair and equitable
rights opportunities and access to
resources but it's become controversial
and nebulous because we've stopped
talking about what working for social
justice actually looks like working for
social justice can look like this or
this it can look like this or it can
look like this or my favorite it can
look like that those are my students and
whenever I'm asked to articulate my work
or my priorities as a teacher I explain
that I believe education can be a tool
for social justice but a few months ago
I logged onto Twitter as I do and I saw
that a fellow teacher had taken issue
with that belief teachers he said should
not be social justice warriors because
the purpose of education is to educate
and he ended his argument by saying I
teach my subject but I reject that
simplification because teachers don't
just teach subjects we teach people when
our students walk into our classrooms
they bring their identities with them
everything they experience in our rooms
is bound up in historical context and so
if we insist that education happens in a
vacuum we do our students a disservice
we teach them that education doesn't
really matter because it's not relevant
to what's happening all around them and
what's happening all around them well
racism for one according to results of
the implicit association test fully 88%
of white people harbored subconscious
biases against black people believing
them to be less intelligent lazier and
more dangerous than whites and that's
just one concrete example of the
insidious effects of historic and
systemic racism on our country for more
evidence we could look at incarceration
rates we could look at statistics on
police violence against black people
could look at the opportunity gap in
education so yeah
social justice belongs in our schools
social justice should be a part of the
mission of every school and every
teacher in America if we want liberty
and justice for all to be more than a
slogan because schools are crucial
places for children to become active
citizens and to learn the skills and the
tools that they need to change the world
so what are those skills ok here's a
secret many of the skills that people
need to orchestrate the kinds of change
that will lead to justice are already
built into the work of schools things
like problem solving critical thinking
collaboration perseverance none of that
should be revolutionary on its own
combine that with the ability to
understand history not as one static and
objective narrative on which we all
agree but as a series of intertwined
events about which there can be
countless interpretations if we
deliberately choose to explore history
with our students rather than just teach
it we help them understand that history
is ongoing and that it's connected to
current movements for justice and we
help them see themselves as potential
players within a living history so those
are the skills I'm talking about when I
say that education can be a place to
help kids learn how to work for justice
but maybe the reason that my Twitter
critic wasn't happy with that idea is
because he doesn't agree with my
definition of justice fair enough maybe
he and I don't see eye to eye
politically but here's the thing our aim
is to encourage students to articulate
their own opinions not to coerce them
into agreeing with us so it actually
doesn't matter if he and I agree what
matters is that we're helping students
have those conversations with each other
and that means that as adults we need to
learn how to become effective
facilitators of our students activism
we've got to help them learn how to have
really tricky conversations we have to
expose them to different opinions and we
have to have to help them see how what
they're learning in school connects to
the world outside
so here's an example of that every year
my students study the history of
apartheid in South Africa as a case
study of injustice now for those of you
who don't know apartheid was a brutally
racist system and the white ruled
government in South Africa imposed
racist laws to oppress people of color
and if you resisted those laws you
risked jail time violence or death and
around the country other around the
world are other countries governments
including ours in the United States
hesitated to sanction South Africa
because well we benefited from its
resources so in 1976 the South African
government passed a new law which
required that all students in South
Africa learn in the language Afrikaans
which was a white language and many
black South Africans referred to that
language as the language of the
oppressor so not surprisingly students
of color were outraged at this law they
already attended segregated schools with
overcrowded classrooms a lack of
resources and a frankly racist
curriculum and now they were being told
to learn in a language neither they nor
their teachers spoke so on the morning
of June 16th 1976 thousands of kids from
the township of Soweto
walked out of schools and they marched
peacefully through the streets to
protest the law at an intersection they
met up with the police and when the kids
refused to turn back the police officers
set dogs on them and then they opened
fire the saguaro uprising ended in
tragedy
apartheid itself didn't end until almost
20 years later but the activism of those
kids in Soweto profoundly changed the
way the world viewed what was happening
in South Africa news outlets all around
the world published this photo of
13-year old Hector Pieterson who was one
of the first people killed by police in
Soweto and it became nearly impossible
to ignore the brutality of the apartheid
regime in the months and the years that
followed the saguaro uprising more and
more countries exerted political and
economic pressure on the South African
government to
and apartheid and it was largely due to
the activism of those kids in Soweto so
every year my kids learn about this and
invariably
they start to draw connections between
those kids in Soweto and themselves and
they start to ask themselves what kind
of political power and agency they have
they ask themselves whether there would
ever be a reason they would risk their
lives so that a future generation could
live in a more just world and most
profoundly for me every single year they
ask themselves whether adults will ever
listen to their voices a few years ago
my principal got an anonymous email from
one of our students it informed him that
the following day the students plan to
walk out of school this was in the wake
of Michael Brown's death in Ferguson
Missouri and the students were planning
to join a walkout and march in support
of the black lives matter movement so at
this point the staff at the school had a
decision to make would we use our
authority and our power to try to
control the students and prevent them
from leaving or would we support them as
they put into practice the principles of
social justice that we had taught them
about since their ninth grade year so
the next morning the kids left school on
mass and they gathered on the lawn and
one of the seniors jumped up on a picnic
table and went over safety expectations
and the younger kids took it very
seriously and as teachers and as staff
we told them okay be safe and we watched
as they marched off the kids who chose
to stay spent that afternoon in class
they debated the merits of protests they
talked about the history of the black
lives matter movement and they went on
with classes as scheduled and those who
chose to leave participated in a
citywide student walkout and raised
their collective voice for justice but
no matter where they chose to spend the
afternoon our kids learned valuable
lessons that day they learned that the
adults in their lives would support them
even as we worried for their safety and
they learned that they didn't need us to
tell them how or when or even why to
protest
they learned that they were members of a
community of young people with a shared
vision of a more equitable society and
they learned that they had power within
that society they learned that events
like the Soweto uprising are not ancient
history and they don't have to end in
tragedy and that's what education as a
tool for social justice can look like
and here's the thing our kids are ready
for this kind of work so in 2015
incoming college freshmen were surveyed
and eight point five percent of them
said that they would there was a very
good chance they would participate in a
protest sometime during their college
career and that might not seem very
impressive but consider the fact that
it's the largest number of students to
say that since 1967 and 75 percent of
those kids said that helping other
people who are having difficulty was a
very important or essential goal for
them again the highest number of people
to say that since the late 1960s and
research shows us that working for
justice doesn't just follow from
building all those skills I talked about
earlier it actually goes the other way
too
so working for justice engaging in
activism help students build skills like
leadership and critical thinking and it
correlates positively with their
political participation and their civic
engagement and their commitment to their
communities later in life so in other
words students are telling us that
social justice matters to them and
researchers are telling us that it helps
students learn so now it's up to us to
listen and that might not be easy in
one of those kids who participated in
Soweto and the uprising he said that
that event represented divorce between
black children and their families
because their families had grown up
under apartheid and they knew how
dangerous it was to speak out they
wanted their kids to lay low and stay
safe and when our kids threatened to
walk out a lot of the adults in our
community were really conflicted - some
of us worried that they might encounter
violence other people worried that they
would walk out but they wouldn't really
know why they were protesting and some
including some students families were
really angry that the school hadn't done
more to prevent them from leaving
and all of those fears that adults have
about getting this stuff wrong all of
those fears make total sense but despite
those fears we've got to prove to our
students that we will listen to their
voices and that they do have the power
to affect change it's our responsibility
to equip our students with the tools and
the skills that they need to insist on a
more equitable world and then sometimes
to get out of their way and let them
apply those skills to things that they
care about and living up to that vision
is going to require that we are flexible
and it's going to require that we're
creative it's going to require that
we're brave enough to stand up in the
face of people who try to silence or D
legitimize dissenting voices and hardest
of all it's going to require accepting
the fact that sometimes we will be the
ones our students will rebel against
sometimes they're going to point out
ways in which systems that we have
created or in which we are complicit
contribute to inequity it's going to be
uncomfortable and it's going to be
painful as they push us to question our
own assumptions and beliefs but what if
we change the way we think about
rebellion in our kids when our kids
rebel when they thoughtfully push back
against our ideas or the way that we do
things what if we chose to see that as a
sign that we're doing something right
and that they're becoming liberated I
know it would be easier if their
critical thinking skills manifested in
more convenient ways on their essays or
their standardized tests I get it but
convenience and justice do not often go
hand-in-hand and when our kids learn to
think critically about the world around
them they become the kinds of engaged
citizens who will recognize and question
injustice when they see it and work to
do something about it
welcoming rebellion into our schools is
going to require some rethinking about
what teaching and learning look like
because there's this misconception that
if we give students any wiggle room
they're gonna walk all over us
and classrooms and dinner tables will
devolve into total chaos and if we
expect kids to sit silently and
passively receive knowledge from us then
their voices will always feel
overwhelming but if we accept instead
that learning is sometimes messy that it
requires opportunities to brainstorm and
mess up and try again that our kids
dislike chaos and want to learn when
they come to school then we can set up
schools to facilitate that kind of
learning so do me a favor and close your
eyes for a second and imagine schools
where teachers are thought partners
letting students grapple with complex
hard issues and not necessarily giving
them the right answers and imagine
schools where we let students make
choices we trust them enough to do that
and we let them experience the
consequences of those choices
imagine schools where we let students be
humans with all of the messiness and the
uncertainty that is bound to come with
that and whatever you just imagined it's
not mythical it's not unrealistically
idealistic because teachers all over the
country are already pushing the
boundaries of what teaching and learning
can look like with amazing results for
kids they're doing that in all kinds of
schools and there are countless models
for teachers who want to get better at
helping students learn in a way that's
more authentic and engaging and
empowering I was reading a book recently
it's called the students are watching
and is by Ted and Nancy sizer and in
that book they said that the work of
Education is often described as a series
of nouns like respect honesty integrity
and they say those nouns sound really
impressive but often they fail to
actually mean anything in practice but
verbs they say are active no less
demanding but requiring constant
engagement verbs are not structured
but rather engines and so as I've read
that I wondered how do we make justice
into an engine driving our work as
teachers what's the verb form of Justice
I think there might be an answer to be
found in the words of Cornel West who
famously said that justice is what love
looks like in public and all of my nerdy
English teachers in the crowd know that
love can be a noun and a verb school has
to be bigger it has to mean more than I
teach my subject school has to be about
teaching people to change the world for
the better if we believe that then
teaching will always be a political act
we can't be afraid of our students power
their power will help them make tomorrow
better but before they can do that we
have to give them chances to practice
today and that practice should start in
our schools thank you very much
[Applause]